you're not to contact or interfere with  little Coombs activities whose side are  you on the comb colony disengaged this  time through the court or not if there's  a place you've never been there's a  scientist wants to know what's there we  have a counter movement that says we are  not going down without a fight  you think I'm gonna let you do your job  and I'll do mine they've taken advantage  of us at every turn and you let it  happen  look who's got big plans do someone like  you  Mars is for those willing to accept a  much higher level of danger even if that  costs a lot of human lives initiating  final prep before detonation go will we  make mistakes on Mars yes I came here to  find life not at the expense of it a  small price to pay  [Music]  you